[Music]
if the process of seeing differently is
the process of first and foremost having
awareness of the fact that everything
you do has an assumption figure out what
those are and by the way the best person
to reveal your own assumptions to you is
not yourself it's usually someone else
hence the power of diversity the
importance of diversity because not only
does that diversity reveal your own
assumptions to you but it can also
complexify your assumptions right
because we know from complex systems
theory that the best solution is most
likely to exist within a complex search
space not a simple search space simply
because of statistics so whereas a
simple search space is more adaptable
it's more easily to adapt it's less
likely to contain the best solution so
what we really want is a diversity of
possibilities a diversity of assumptions
which diverse groups for instance enable
but also diverse experience so one of
the best ways to diversify complexify
your search space your assumptions is
through experience and one of the great
ways to do that is actually through
technology so we think about technology
when most of our technologies are good
technologies but what defines a great
technology what is the transformative
technology the good technologies are the
ones that enable us to do what we can
already do faster easier more efficient
and that's because so much of our
society focuses on efficiency it's about
maximizing performance right we're great
engineers but we're crap philosophers
right we're very good at making things
more efficient but that's only one side
of innovation we also need the other
side of innovation which is creativity
and so the best technologies are the
ones in my view that make the invisible
visible they enable us to see things
that we can never have seen before they
create assumptions they expand our space
of assumptions we typically think of
course Oh
visual technologies but we can also
think of the telescope the microscope in
fact we can even think of the sale
so the sale was in one sense invented on
the Nile it's because the currents and
the wind going off the directions so you
could sail up current and then you could
float back down but what the sail
enables to do was to travel which meant
we could see different Ecology's
different cultures which when approached
in an open way enabled us to not only
challenge but expand our assumptions
because we would have incorporated their
biases into our own so you could view it
in a different way the best
transformative technologies enable us to
travel right but not just travel
physically travel in our minds so a book
writing this also leads on to things
like augmented reality and even virtual
reality so in our case we've actually
done experiments and created a whole
platform in augmented reality to see if
we can explore how the brain makes
meaning by engaging with a new layer in
the world not to replace the real world
but to expand it another example is the
free space belt so what this was was a
belt that was in fact a belt right went
around your waist and affected what it
did is it vibrated in the direction of
North which effectively gave people the
ability to see what they couldn't see
before they made the invisible visible
and what happened is that people would
consciously use make reference well
initially they just felt a vibration and
then they started incorporating it into
their movement into the navigation
consciously but he eventually became
unconscious to the point that when they
actually removed the belt they felt
insecure so effectively they were almost
turning people into birds right who were
able to detect magnetic north in their
migrations and the brain was able to
adapt and redefine normality based on
this new information that was getting
but not just the data the meaning of the
data by physically engaging with the
world because only in that sense did it
come to literally make sense
[Music]